تحيه طيبه مشاهدينا الكرام واهلا ومرحبا
بكم مع هذا اللقاء الحصري والخاص مع
المفكر الروسي والفيلسوف الشهير الكسندر
دوكن الكسندر
شكرا لكم على الاستضافه دعونا نبدا مباشره
بهذا السؤال كيف تقيمون الوضع في اوكرانيا
اليوم
الرئيسيه اعتقد ان روسيا في حاله حرب
طويله جدا ومخيفه جدا وجديه للغايه
عسكريه محدوده محليه خاطفه وسريعه للغايه
وراميه الى تغيير النظام السياسي في
اوكرانيا واجبارها على رفض الانضمام
للناتو والامتناع عن العسكره وعن
الايديولوجي النازيه ولكن تبين بعد مرور
بعض الوقت ان ذلك لم يتحقق اي انه من خلال
تلك الاهداف وبتلك الوسائل وضمن المده
التي تم التخطيط فيها كان ذلك مستحيلا
لانه تبين اندماج اوكرانيا في والغرب كان
اعماق لقد تم الرهان على عدد من السياسيين
المعارضين الاوكرانيين لكن هذا الشيء لم
ينجح اذ تم تقييدهم وتحيدهم على الفور
وجدت روسيا نفسها في حاله حرب لم نقم
مستعدين لها ولم نعول عليها ولم نكن
نريدها لكننا وجدنا انفسنا في هذه الحرب
ولم ياتي ادراكما حدث الا في الخريف فقط
بعد اعلان التعبئه وفقدان مواقعنا في
خاركف عندما بدانا في التراجع وبدا عدونا
في التقدم وراينا حجم امدادات الاسلحه
الغربيه والاستعداد السياسي والاقتصاديه
والدبلوماسيه الغربي لدعم كييف الى اقصى
حد حينها ادركنا انها حقيقيه كامله لا
توجد لها نهايه في الافق كما يقول الروس
كاتو كراي فيدنا اذا هل يمكن القول ان
العمليه العسكريه تتحولت الى حرب حقيقيه
بشكل غير رسمي
حقيقه الامر ان جميع اصر في البدايه على
ان نقول عمليه عسكريه خاصه فقط حتى انه
اعتمد قرار بمنع تسميتها حربا ولكن وبحلول
ربيع بدايه الصيف تقريبا بات المزيد من
محللين يستخدمون مرادفتين عمليه عسكريه
خاصه وحرب موسكو لم تعلن الحرب على
اوكرانيا وهذا صحيح ويجب تذكره لكن في
الواقع بات الجميع اليوم يدرك ان هذه حرب
مع الغرب بايدي الاوكرانيين
هل كان من الممكن تجنب العمليه العسكريه
الخاصه من اجل ماذا تقاتل روسيا في
اوكرانيا
بعد الانقلاب العسكري في اوكرانيا في 2014
بات من المستحيل تجنب الحرب خصوصا بعد ضم
موسكو للقرم وانفصال الدمباس الطريقه
الوحيده لتجنب الحرب في عام 2022 كان
بداها في عام 2014 اي اصاله تحرير النظر
او على الاقل الى نهاياتها المنطقيه
وحقيقه اننا انضممنا الى اتفاقيه ميسك
كانت خطا بدلا من استغلال ذلك الوقت
للتحضير لعام 2022
صدقنا فعلا اتفاقيه منسك بينما استغل
الغرب ذلك الوقت كاستراحه لقد كان ذلك خطا
استراتيجيا جديا من قبل قيادتنا التي لم
ترغب في مواجهه الحقيقه امر اخر هو انه
خلال عهد رئاسه كانت لتلاشت شده هذا
الصراع العسكري لانه لا يسعى لهدف رئيسي
متمثل في القضاء على روسيا كما هو الحال
بالنسبه
الحرب كانت حتميه لكن السؤال هو عاجلا ام
عاجلا
ما هو مستقبل اوكرانيا من وجهه نظركم
اوكرانيا لن تكون موجوده على الاطلاق في
هذه الحرب التي نخوضها مع الغرب هناك
مفترق الطرق التالي انها حرب خطيره لدرجه
ان روسيا لا يمكن ان تخسرها بل يمكنها ان
تنتهي لا يمكن ان تقول حسنا سنتخلى الان
على المناطق التي استولينا عليها حين ذلك
سيحدث انفجار داخلي ستغرق روسيا في حرب
اهليه لا يمكن لروسيا ان تخسر باي شكل
لانه بالتراجع خطوه الى الوراء سنتراجع
الف خطوه الى الوراء ستقاتل روسيا حتى
النهايه ببساطه لاننا لا نستطيع التوقف لا
يمكننا ان نخسر لن نكون راضينا الا عن
تحرير اوكرانيا باكملها من النخبه
السياسيه المواليه لحلف الناتو مهما كان
الثمن هذا ما سيعتبر انتصارا لنا
لكن ما الذي يعتبر انتصارا للغرب لقد تحقق
النصر له بالفعل لقد ربح الغرب هذه الحرب
فور جره لروسيا من خلال تنفيذه لانقلاب في
كييف ومن خلال اخضاع روسيا لجميع انواع
العقوبات وعصدها عن العالم اي ان الغرب
فاس ربما ليس اوروبا ولكن الغرب ككل
الولايات المتحده لقد فازوا لانهم عسلونا
اصبح تاثيرنا على اوروبا الان صفرا تقريبا
في الواقع لقد عززوا وحشدوا صفوف الناتو
يحقق العزله الدوليه لروسيا على الاقل من
جانب تلك الدول وهي كثيره جدا التي تخضع
للنفوذ الامريكيه المباشر هذا انتصار
انتصار كبير باستخدام قوات اخرى من غير
الدخول في الحرب مباشره لا يمكن لروسي ان
تخسر بل يجب ان تنتصر فقط لكي تكون لا لكي
تفوز حتى ولو سلبا
بينما ليس لدى اوكرانيا فرصه لتقوم في مثل
هذه الحاله لانه اذا كانت روسيا موجوده لن
يكون هناك اوكرانيا سيقبل الغرب هذا بهدوء
لان روسيا ستصبح اقل خطوره بعد توجيه ضربه
الى بنيه التحتيه ولخط انابيب الغاز
وسنكون لفتره طويله مشغولين بفعل شيء حيال
هذه المناطق الجديده
روسيا بنفسها لن تستخدم سلاح النووي لذلك
لا يوجد تهديد بحرب نوويه من جانب روسيا
ولكن هناك تهديد في حال بدات روسيا تخسر
في هذه الحاله يمكن ان تستخدم روسيا على
اسلحه النوويه وبالتالي اذا تم السماح
لروسيا بالانتصار فسيكون ذلك انتصارا
للغرب وهزيمه لروسيا لكن مع الحفاظ عليها
وخلاص البشريه لكن لن تكون هناك اوكرانيا
في اي من هذه الحالات انها ستختفي اذا
انتصرنا ستختفي مع الانسانيه اذا بدات
نهايه العالم النوويه انها ستختفي حتى لو
تخيلنا انها انتصرت ولكن بعد وفاه هذا
الكم من الناس وتدمير كل البنيه التحتيه
لا احد ينوي اعاده بناء هذا البلد الضخم
لذلك اوكرانيا غير موجوده في الواقع كل ما
كان علينا فعله هو عدم تدمير الاتحاد
السوفيتي او دق رقبتك
في الوقت المناسب
بعد مرور عام على الحرب هل تعتقدون ان
العالم بات يصبح متعدد الاقطاب
ناتشوس
الانتقال من عالم احادي القطب لمتعدد
الاقطاب بدا مع وصول بوتين الى سده الحكم
وشيجي بنك في الصين لقد خلقوا الشروط
المسبقه لعالم متعدد الاقطاب عندما بدا
الصراع في اوكرانيا بات هذا هو الاختبار
الاخير ولا كان نصرا سريعا وكاسحا لو
ظفرنا به
لنا بالقول نعم العالم الان متعدد الاقطاب
لكنه ليس كذلك نحن الان متواجدون في هذا
الانتقال المخيف الى عالم متعدد الاقطاب
يمكن ان يكون لهذا عواقب كبيره جدا على
سبيل المثال يمكن انتقال ذلك الى منطقه
اخرى انا لا استبعد ان يكون هناك تصعيد في
الشرق الاوسط وان يكون هناك صراع اسرائيلي
ايراني وصيني تايواني كلها حروب عالم
متعدد الاقطار قد يكون هناك تازر بين
كوريا الشماليه وكوريا الجنوبيه او
اليابان لكن لا يمكننا القول ان العالم
بات بالفعل متعدد الاقطاب لانه لا توجد
مؤسسات والغرب لا ينوي اضعاف هيمنته لقد
تشبث بها وبدا يحتضر
لماذا يعتبرونكم الملهمه الرئيسيه
للكرملين هل تعت ان هذا الشيء صحيح لمكرم
بالطبع لا هذا ليس صحيحا الغرب لصق بياس
صفه راس بوتين نحن نعلم ان الغرب يحب قتل
راس بوتين يحب قتل القياصره الروس ويحب
شبك المؤامرات لقد حاولوا شرح نظريه انا
شخصا شريرا سيئا وهو روسيا بلحيه ويبدو
وكانه ممثل تقليدي عن الشعب الروسي له
تاثير على الكريم وعلى المجتمع ويعتبر
مصدر الشر المطلق انه تجاهل كامل لبلدنا
ولتاريخه ولتقافته انا امثل نفسي اذا شئتم
فيلسوفا وطنيا مفكرا اتابع تاريخ شعبي
وافهم انماط هذا التاريخ وادرس جيوسياسيه
بعمق واحلل العمليات الاجتماعيه والسياسيه
والانتروبولوجيه وتعامل مع الثقافه
وبالطبع ومباشره بعد نهايه الاتحاد
السوفيتي ادركت ان الصراع الغرب لا مفر
منه وبدات في تاكيد ذلك لكن ليس لانني
اثرت على بوتين فيما اعترفه وبذلك بل لان
واقع الحال يؤكد ذلك اي انها حركه موضوعيه
للاشياء في الواقع اعتقد ان بوتين يحمل
وجهات نظر مختلفه فهو يعتبر انه من
الضروري التفاوض مع الغرب وان روسيا جزء
من الحضاره الاوروبيه الغربيه ربما لا
يعجبه الوضع الحديث لحضاره اوروبا الغربيه
فهو ينتقد ذلك على نيه لكنه يشعر بالتعاطف
مع الليبراليه القديمه وهكذا في رايي فان
الغرب هو مصدر الشر المطلق ويدمر الاسره
والجنس والانسان بطبعه من خلال الذكاء
الاصطناعي اعتقد ان المسلمين يفهمونني
جيدا لانني اعتقد ان الغرب هو دجال بينما
لا يعتبر بوتين ذلك على الاطلاق بل يعتبر
ان الغرب هو شريك يتصرف بعدوانيه شديده
لسبب ما الان نحن حاله حرب معه لان شريكه
قرر القتال معنا ولو لم يكن قرر القتال
لكننا نزوده الان بالنفط والغاز الرخيصين
لكن ربما الثقه الان مفقوده تماما خاصه
بعد التصريح الغربي بهذا
انظر لماذا يعتبرونني
لانني افكر بشكل سباقي الى الامام ايا
الغرب هو شرير بالنسبه لي نحن حضاره
ارثوذكسيه اوراسيه مختلفه عن الغرب وكل
شيء لدينا مختلف القيم التقليديه والشخص
يفهمها بطرقته الخاصه وانا اقول ذلك ولا
يهم ما اذا كانوا يتفقون ما املاه قبل
بوتين بوقت طويل تحدثت عن ان الحرب مع
اوكرانيا لا من فر منها وعن انفصال شبه
جزيره القرم وعن تقطيع اوصال اوكرانيا الى
الشرق لاحظ كافه تصريحات بوتين تقريبا
باتت تقول لقد خدعونا هناك خدع في
اتفاقيات منسك خدعونا في التيار الشمالي
فيما لم يخدعني الغرب باي شكل من الاشكال
اراه شريرا كاذبا وغدا عدوا يجب محاربته
بينما بوت لا
لماذا تم استهداف ابنتك داريا
لا يزال تحقيق جاريا يعتقد الكثير من
الناس انها كانت محاوله لاغتيال كان من
المفترض ان اقود تلك السياره وداش اصبحت
ضحيه بدلا مني هذه هي مشيئه الرب بالطبع
بالنسبه لاوكرانيا لا اشكل اي خطر ولا
واثر على الكريم على الاطلاق بوتا يتخذ
قراراته بنفسه لكن الغرب ربما راى تهديدا
في افكاري في كتاب النظريه السياسيه
الرابعه الذي ينتشر في جميع انحاء العالم
في جيوسياسيه في التقليديه في معارضه
الليبراليه في كفاح من اجل عالم متعدد
الاقطاب في هذا الصدد يراني الغرب اكثر
تباينا بكثير مما الغالبيه هنا في روسيا
يراني كنقيد له كشخص يدرك منطقه ليقوم
بانشاء منظومه قيم مناقضه له تماما فقرروا
ابعاد بهذا الشكل بعيد الارهابيين
الاوكرانيين اوكرانيا
منهم حلفاء موسكو الحقيقيون اليوم بوجهه
نظرك
[موسيقى]
نحن ربما كما هو الحال في كثير من الاحيان
في التاريخ اخذنا على عاتقنا وطات الضربه
الرئيسيه حتى اقرب حليف الصين لا تفهمون
تماما اي انها تستفيد بالتاكيد من ذاك
النضال من اجل التعدديه القطبيه فهي
تدعمنا لكنها ليست متضامنه معنا حتى
النهايه مع ذلك يا نصيبيين عموما اكثر
عقلانيه ولديهم سياسه افضل مما لدينا وهم
يعتقد اخفاقاتنا خلال الحرب هي نتيجه
حساباتنا الخاطئه من التسعينات
يتعلمون من اخطائنا ويتاسفون عندما
نرتكبها اذ حقا لا يعجبهم ضعفنا لكنهم غير
مستعدين للمخاطره بكل شيء لدعمنا انهم
حلفاؤنا لكن كما ولو متنحونا على بعد نصف
خطوه تهتم العديد من القوى بعالم متعدد
الاقطاب لانفسها اعتقد ان الهند بكل
اعجابها بالغرب هي بالتاكيد مستفيده من
هذه التعدديه القطبيه العالم الاسلامي
الذي يسعى في كثير من مراكزه ونقاطه الى
الاستقلال عن الهيمنه الغربيه رغم انه
منقسم وليس مستقلا لديه العديد من
الصراعات الداخليه لكنني اشعر بتعاطف
كبيره من جهه العالم العربي العالم
الاسلامي ككل اعتقد ان امريكا اللاتينيه
تدرك ايضا نوع الاهداف الوطنيه العليا
التي روسيا لتحقيقها في هذه الحرب والقاره
الافريقيه كذلك
السيد الكسندر شكرا جزيلا لكم ولكم
مشاهدينا الكرام كل الشكر على حسن
المتابعه دمتم في رعايه الله والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]